[Music]
saturn's largest moon
titan is unique it has its own
atmosphere
not only that it's the only planet or
moon other than earth to have bodies of
liquid on its surface
would it be possible to take a dip in
one of these lakes
what would the liquid feel like and how
far could you swim
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you could swim
in titan's lakes titan is the second
largest moon in our entire solar system
it's bigger than our moon and even
bigger than the planet mercury
despite being so large titan has a weak
gravitational pull
let's say you weigh 70 kilograms here on
earth on titan
you'd weigh just 10. unfortunately this
means you won't be doing any epic
cannonballs into titan's lakes
if you could find a cliff to jump off it
would take you quite a while
to float down to the surface of the
liquid but when you finally reach the
lake
you'll plummet to the bottom extremely
fast
the reason you'd have such a hard time
keeping your head above the surface
is due to the liquid methane and ethane
found in titan's lakes
the density of liquid methane is much
much lower than water
so you wouldn't be as buoyant swimming
on earth is easy
because humans aren't as dense as water
when we're in a swimming pool
we weigh less than the amount of water
that we displace
and the force of the water pushing back
on us helps to keep us afloat
in titan's lakes your body would be much
more dense than the liquid methane
you're attempting to swim in
it would feel as if you were made of
stone on the surface of the lake
the liquid methane would appear
completely clear but you still wouldn't
be able to see too deep
due to the dark rock and thick
atmosphere on the moon
in fact titan only receives one percent
of the sunlight
we receive here on earth i should remind
you that
you wouldn't even get this far without
wearing a special spacesuit
it would have to be strong enough to
withstand the temperature of titan's
surface
a frosty 178 degrees below zero
you'd also need it to protect you from
the lack of oxygen on the moon
the deadly levels of nitrogen gas and
the gasoline like rains
okay back to you being underwater or
under liquid methane
from the bottom of the lake to get back
up to the surface you'd need to swim up
200 meters once you reach the surface
you'd quickly realize just how
big the lake you're in is this is kraken
mare which is
000 square kilometers for a reference
that's bigger than the caspian sea
the largest lake on earth and bigger
than the entire country of japan
if you don't like this lake you have
over 50 other lakes to choose from
depending on what kind of view you're
interested in
unfortunately there's no surfing on
these lakes you won't find any waves on
titan
as its low gravity makes it resistant to
creating them
so all in all not a great day at the
beach
swimming in these lakes would be pretty
tricky and
not a lot of fun on top of that it's not
likely that you'll be able to relax on
the shore
or suntan maybe it isn't the best
vacation spot but
you certainly can't deny the beautiful
view now what would happen if you were a
space tourist
and could travel anywhere you wanted
well that sounds like a question
for another what if
you